a very peaceful in a very uh fulfilling
Journey you shouldn't be drinking you
shouldn't be important you shouldn't be
going to clubs or anything like that so
uh and really accepting my place in life
as a Muslim um did you get a chance what
would uh to watch that what was your
reaction some of the most disciplined
people that I know are very religious
it's really fascinating particularly
Fighters like a lot of the Islamic
Fighters and it just made so much more
sense did he did Jon Jones also say it
well I converted him now Muslim I'm good
sir how are you doing oh man I'm doing a
God is so good yeah I think you said it
perfect right there been a Muslim your
whole life I was so caught up in oh what
do I look like oh is everybody looking
at me I even had that misconception a
little further and he fell on his face
and prayed to who himself no he prayed
to God and I'll look them and no I'm I'm
Muslim I would
assalamualaikum greetings of peace I
have a surprise for you some amazing
news I recently found out that a very
famous veteran formerly with the UFC by
the name of Kevin Lee who is an American
former lightweight champ professional
mixed martial artist he formerly
competed with the UFC EFC and has
recently on ESPN he bravely courageously
announced that he he had accepted
submission to the Creator not the
creation Islam I've accepted Islam right
I've converted over to to Islam now I
really want to know just like you do
what led him to make this decision is it
all the scientific proof mentioned in
the Quran embryo in the Quran cannot be
based on scientific knowledge in the
seventh seventh century
foreign
could not have known these facts about
human development in the 7th Century
because most of them were not discovered
until the 20th century these facts could
only have been revealed to Muhammad by
the one no one who knows all about us
is it a simple message of the purpose of
life would it loosen and clear belief in
the absolute Oneness of the Creator is
the Brotherhood the moral code is it the
love of Jesus is a mighty messenger I
love a chance to ask Heavenly myself all
these questions and more would you guys
like that should we get Kevin Lee on The
Dean show
should we well that's my surprise to you
alhamdulillah we got him here with us
for this special episode of the dean
show with Kevin Lee
[Applause]
show
[Music]
how you doing brother it's a pleasure to
be here I'm doing great I'm feeling
great it's it's a pleasure to talk to
you very nice alhamdulillah thank you
for accepting the invitation
yes yeah thank you for extending it
so uh
ESPN you're on ESPN like many of us we
saw this
short clip there I've accepted Islam
right I've converted over to to Islam
how did it lead up to to that that you
came out I don't even know what the
question was before or after I just saw
that clip can you kind of go ahead and
and fill us in how it came to that and
what made you come out on ESPN to
officially announced that you had
accepted Islam yeah I've been pretty uh
selective with with the media that I've
been doing
um especially in the last two years I I
feel like I've been through uh an
extended period of personal growth
um and in this while we're while we're
negotiating my fighting career
um while I'm getting ready to sign a new
contract with with uh different
organization uh the the conversation
that we were having just kind of led to
it in in it uh it led to the
announcement almost it wasn't like I
planned it beforehand but uh in in
mashallah it worked out perfectly uh and
I I think it was just in due time that
that I actually make the announcement
and and tell people and kind of let
people in a little bit more into my
personal life uh my my my religion and
my faith is is is is a personal thing so
so my family everyone around me have
known for for over a year plus uh but it
was time that I let the the public know
as well yeah that's correct it's you
actually made that decision back in 2021
right yeah yeah it was uh October of
2021 where uh I officially walked into a
mosque for the first time and I I Fisher
said the dean and uh and was accepted
share that with me now share that
experience first time walking into the
mosque because I'm trying to get you
know the whole world to come and connect
because we got so many misconceptions
stereotypes and you know there's this
false fear that's created but how was it
you know that first time you go ahead
and you step in and you make that now
now that decision I'm gonna go into moss
and see for myself what's going on with
these Muslims you know what what how was
that experience life and what led you
again to make that even decision to go
ahead and step into Hamas for the first
time yeah I think you said it perfect
right there uh that there is a
misconception
um and I even had that misconception
right uh I can remember uh as a child my
my aunt was always Muslim right she uh
her name Veronica Muhammad and you know
she she would take me with my cousin a
few times to a few months but I'm very
young at this time right I'm seven eight
years old uh but everyone in my family
everybody in the community everybody
kind of had these stigmas around Islam
and Muslims to where I didn't take it
serious I didn't my heart was closed off
because of how everyone uh kind of
always portrayed the religion so I never
really even took it serious uh it's it's
been like a few years and I don't know
how much you want to kind of dig into
this and how much uh uh you know you
want me to talk about it necessarily but
I do feel like it's important however
you however much you feel comfortable
you know we'll dig as much as you feel
comfortable yeah okay okay I I do feel
you know it's important to give people
uh a good storyline that they can that
they can follow that they can understand
to to get to uh to uh to a better
understanding you know yeah tell us
about that please
so I I want to say that this all started
in 2018
um 2018. 2018 was the first time that I
really kind of had my eyes open uh and
for me fighting is a huge part of my
life right I've been a professional for
for over 11 years now
um and it was before my flight with
Rafael dos anjos uh I was fighting a a
former world champion for the first time
and in the locker room of that fight
like it's it's hard for me to explain
right it's hard to explain some of these
things if you haven't experienced it but
it was almost as if my eyes had been
like changed a little bit like they have
been open and it it was strange because
I didn't necessarily know what it meant
and I'm getting ready for this big fight
and you know I'm in the locker room I'm
getting ready to walk out and I can
remember walking with like this crazy
confidence like I just knew everything
seemed to be in sync everything seemed
to be to be to be coming together I
didn't necessarily know what it meant
right
um I end up losing that fight which
created a lot of confusion like why
would this happen in the locker room and
and I end up losing the fight
um and and I went on a crazy and that's
kind of what started this whole this
whole journey and this whole path to
what what does it all mean what what is
what is I I feel like
Allah was speaking to me and and God was
speaking to me in that night and it took
me a long time to to recognize the voice
and to understand it and to to to come
to the understanding and I didn't really
get a a uh my heart didn't really open
up to it being a lot and into it to
being a Muslim was the path that will
get me closer to it until about 2020 uh
after uh
I'm sorry I feel like I feel like I'm
kind of rambling a little bit
too far
no no he's going good you're 2018 you
got something going on now and you're
you know at the point we all come to a
point I mean well we all have our
personal Journeys that we go through and
then you know you're getting jumping in
a cage you're risking your life and now
you're thinking like you know what's
this all about now what's is it the
question that's coming that's simmering
like what's the purpose of life what's
it all about you know what I mean I I
can imagine Kevin look I often give this
example like imagine you jump into this
cage and there's no Go ultimate goal at
the end there's nothing there's no like
no winner there's no points there's
nothing it's just like random you know
what I mean but what about life you know
so are you is that that's what you're
hitting too at this is what's going on
the point in your life exactly exactly
that's that that was kind of the point I
was hitting at in 2018 what does it all
mean right
um and what does it all mean what does
it all mean that's the question okay
and I'm so used to to just kind of okay
just buckling down and just doing what
I'm used to doing right just go back to
fighting go back to what you're used to
doing uh which is what I did in 2019
right 2019 was a was a great year for me
uh I I made necessary adjustments I felt
like I got closer and closer to to the
path that I needed to be on
um that was the the year that I fought
at Madison Square Garden and and all
these great things started happening
right
and then and then my my my uh my my
humbleness kind of went away I started
saying oh it was me that did this oh it
was me it was like oh because I because
I because I'm the man that's why you
started doing it you started doing the
chest bump huh pointing to you exactly
exactly I'm like oh yeah okay of course
this is supposed to happen is
I'm I'm putting in all this hard work so
I'm doing all
and and that's why these good things are
happening yeah I called that the uh
Conor McGregor you know the sure yeah
sure so tell us more keep going this is
interesting yeah
um I was feeling it and then I got
smacked with the reality check in in
2020.
um I I think that's when my my heart was
forced kind of open you know it had been
closed off uh but after I fought Charles
Oliveira
um
which was a great fight right I felt
like I was winning that fight uh it was
it was a great fight in in the moment
but
it it just after the fight it was so
impactful to me
and it really
made me sit and search and think and and
it made me
it it just made me realize like I'm not
necessarily the one that's it that's in
charge of this whole thing you know you
you have to you I almost had to let go I
had to let go and and and and Just
Surrender myself uh
and it took me it took me almost a year
before I before I actually accepted that
and actually realized that that's what I
needed to do uh it wasn't until May of
that year that that
that I started looking toward towards
Muslims that I started that I started
kind of opening my heart up a little bit
that I started listening just just a
little bit more and it just made so much
more sense
um and on my birthday I had an
experience where I felt like God really
came to me and he told me Hey listen you
you've been been a Muslim your whole
life you just you just haven't you just
haven't accepted it you just haven't you
just haven't listened you you've been
stuck in your own your own viewers
you've been stuck in your own in your
own ego for so long
um my birthday is in September and and
after that experience I I decided okay
I'm actually going to open my heart and
actually listen and and and and follow
through and uh since then it's been an
amazing journey since then I've gained
more clarity each and every day I feel
like
every day I put my face on the ground
and I think I'll offer for giving me
this breath for allowing me to to step
and I'm gonna continue to just step in
his shoes and and and
it's a very a very peaceful and a very
uh fulfilling Journey for how you were
saying this just oh I'm just fighting
and there's no really there's no end
goal you know there's some money to be
made yeah sure but but I'm just fighting
just to fight uh now I feel like I'm
fighting for a different reason in the
fight is every day well you know it has
me thinking and I just want to bridge
this Gap uh here because that's what we
kind of try to do is try to Define these
terms help the average American the
average person you know understand like
when we say Muslim you know this is so
close to home when you understand the
meaning a Muslim is just simply one when
you define it one who submits his or her
will to the creator of the heavens and
earth that's what a Muslim is Right
correct uh and you just came back as we
say there's a statement by the last and
final Minister said the mankind Prophet
Muhammad is when someone accepts Islam
they're just coming back to that natural
way you know they're coming back to that
submission because every you're
submitting to something you're either
submit to your desires you're submitting
to uh money Fame to a human being you
came back to that natural way of
worshiping just the creator of the
heavens and earth it just it's something
that makes so much sense and uh you
mentioned Allah Allah people are going
to see now that Jesus peace be upon them
he would he spoke Aramaic and he would
say Allah Allah he would also call on
God Allah so this is now it's like helps
people understand better you know so
they're not thinking something foreign
you know and then uh I mentioned earlier
in the show you had the The Greatest
American Hero of all time Muhammad Ali
he was he was a Muslim he was one who's
following that same way of life uh tell
me this so now how is it and you said
you put your face on the ground if
someone opens up the Bible and quote
sees Jesus and he went a little further
and he fell on his face and prayed to
who himself no he prayed to God just
like you you're doing the same way how
was that experience and you see Habib
doing it after his fights also he's
saying alhamdulillah he's praising God
we even saw Jon Jones saying
alhamdulillah you know yeah did Jon
Jones also yeah yeah I'll say he said it
yeah I I can send you the uh the clips
well I converted him now Muslim I'm
I'm Madonna God is so good uh I did a
program on this uh and this is this is
kind of like saying hallelujah like I'll
pray to not yourself you know but to
like Habib does like pointing up above
you know to the Creator that's it so how
is it now when you first made what's
called sejada when you put your face on
the ground you humbled yourself you know
how was it uh Malcolm X when he did this
the first time he said things would
never be the same you know what I mean
it was just that humbleness you know
just connecting with God Almighty how
was your experience with that when you
first time and now you're continuing
obviously to establish the prayer
when when I first did it right and I'm
and I'm gonna try to be as uh candid and
as open as possible yes please uh uh
when I first did I was it was so foreign
and it was such a
it was it was it took a lot right it
took it took a lot for me to to just
kind of bow down really like literally
literally yeah figuratively that's what
Malcolm was talking about yes yeah it
took it took an incredible amount of of
I I don't I don't necessarily know the
word for it um
but it just it took a lot and and the
first time that I did I I was so caught
up in oh what do I look like oh is
everybody looking at me no what is what
is I was so caught up in in
my own ego of of being here still
um I want to say it took me about a good
four or five months before I really just
just now it's such a peaceful and it's
such a it's such a it's such a rich
ritualistic thing to me that I don't
necessarily think about it it just it
just gives me peace now right it just
gives me it's it's just it's it's almost
like walking you know I don't after you
do it for so long you just you don't
even think about it yeah that's just
normal
um but the first time I I I'll have to
say is is extremely it's it's hard it's
very hard would you say because you were
fighting What's called the Neffs you
were finding fighting your inner self it
said yeah you called Jihad that
struggled now yeah and it was that tug
of war back and forth so you had to like
you have to submit it right and it's
hard to know who to give into right yeah
and I think you said uh I think you said
it good earlier is is even people who
who don't necessarily recognize
themselves as Muslims they're still
giving it to something right you're
still you're you're gonna it's that's
just a way of human nature you're gonna
Bow Down or something and I think I've
spent so long and bowing down to my own
ego and in my own uh what What's the
word to use for it no no this is that uh
yes this is the Neffs this is the ego
this is the self you know the inner self
that wants this wants that wants you
know that fulfillment you know other
than what you get what you're giving it
all the things that can be harming it
are harmful for it you know okay so yeah
exactly that's a great way of putting it
and I'm still learning a lot
um
so yeah I think I think that that was a
very hard battle to the first half uh
but what's kept me on the path and you
you've even mentioned it I think the
greatest fighters in in the world uh and
the greatest fighters in history have
always been Muslim and they've always uh
accepted that you you talk about
Muhammad Ali Mike Tyson uh I feel like
Floyd Mayweather even uh even though
Floyd isn't coming out publicly and
saying it he still lives his life in in
a lot of the same way that that Muslims
do is there something we don't know that
Floyd Mayweather did you hear something
is is he does he come into Islam
investigating Islam Floyd Mayweather did
he accept this
I I've heard Rumblings
um but you you're not going to hear it
directly from me I think uh that's a
very personal thing so yeah I got
something something that you have to ask
him but but as far as as far as living
his life and living his life in the
correct way and and praying and and uh I
think he's very much uh along that path
yes tell me this um you've also been
blessed to how important is it with good
companionship good friends you got uh
brother Saeed who's around you also uh
he's your coach one of your coaches your
coach and uh
he's uh someone like him and others you
know have did you get a chance to spend
some time also with khabib was he able
to also be a good influence on you and
others like that uh seeing you know
what's different about these guys you
know we could be out doing business but
a time comes and now they're like hold
on we got to go pray Hold On We're not
gonna go drinking hold on let's go to
the club you know after party right uh
Nick Diaz let's go to I'll meet you at
the after part no no we ain't going to
after party right so do these things
stand out
uh absolutely and I think the first
person to to introduce me to that is is
for Raza hobby
um
yeah yeah he he was the first person to
to introduce me to it with Without
Really uh doing it and is not doing it
directly right just by seeing the way
that he lived oh you yeah he operated uh
I went to him in 2019 and and like I
told you it's that's the year that I
felt like I shined the most uh I was
spending the most amount of time with
with him in in uh in Canada uh before
this whole craziness with Kobe in it and
all that stuff is going on
um but yeah for Faraz uh my brother
Saeed there's there's been a lot of
people
um especially since I made the
announcement that have come out and give
me support and they're all super
disciplined
um and they just they they have the
thing that I've always liked and I've I
feel they don't beat themselves
um I haven't met a devout Muslim yet
that that beats themselves in the way
that that I have before
I remember you reminded me now of
farazabi yeah wow um I interviewed um
him but I also had a mirassad vectic he
was also with you guys yeah he went
through uh if you can watch the
interview I did with him he talks about
same thing he kind of let his you know
mind and he lost Direction and then he
felt like he got humbled you know what I
mean same thing and then that helped to
bring him back on what he needed to be
upon and he'd also uh somebody who you
trained with didn't you and uh yeah in
Canada yeah I realized that you uh that
you also interviewed yeah yeah yes yes
yeah he spent some time with us also in
Chicago wow okay yeah yeah he's he's
incredibly smart he's incredibly smart
he's a great mind
um not just for MMA but for life in
general he's he's incredible so tell me
this uh recently you had uh did you see
Joe Rogan he was actually praising the
Muslim Fighters did you see that uh
where he was coming out and he was what
we're talking about actually Joe Rogan
was talking about you know does this
discipline and and you know not getting
caught up into Hedonism did you get a
chance what would uh to watch that what
was your reaction some of the most
disciplined people that I know are very
religious it's really fascinating it's
particularly Fighters like a lot of the
Islamic Fighters out of Dagestan they're
some of the most dominant Fighters and
some of the most religious Fighters so
devout and because they don't have the
distractions that a lot of the hedonists
do yeah you know they're not party like
the guys out of khabib nurmagamanos camp
or some of the most dominant Fighters
they're they wear their hair all exactly
the same way they practice all they care
about is like family religion training
they they don't chase girls they don't
drink they're just they're they're just
training constantly like insanely
dedicated to their craft and they're the
most dominant khabib is very wealthy
yeah and he drives a Toyota truck I mean
he's uh he lives in the same house I
mean it's like he's very devout in his
beliefs and the way he's raising other
Fighters and now he just got out I think
he's decided to retire completely from
mixed martial arts coaching and
everything very religious um I I haven't
but I think I I maybe did see a clip
where he was asking I think that for a
fighter having a religion like that
especially being devout it does have an
advantage in that that's one more thing
you don't have to think about yeah and
it also just builds you up from you when
you're a kid just the discipline of yeah
I know I have to do this this and this
every single day I'm not allowed so
important eat this I'm not allowed to
eat pork I'm not allowed to do this I'm
not allowed to gamble I'm not allowed to
play drink or anything like that so it
puts you in those things and a lot of
those things are worse for you as a
fighter anyway like you shouldn't be
drinking you shouldn't be important you
shouldn't be going to clubs or anything
like that so in the end I think it's
like the
being that's why you've seen most of the
Muslims starting to be the best fighters
out there where he was asking Bilal and
he was asking him how okay how uh how it
is training with with a lot of the
dagestani guys
um and I know pretty much all of them
are all Muslim you know and he talked
about the discipline that that they kind
of have
um and day in and day out you know and I
really feel like that's where the fights
are won
um and especially me I I've been in I've
been fighting for a long time right I've
had uh almost 30 professional fights at
this point the the the best fights are
always one when I'm when I'm strictly
disciplined
um before the fight they they're always
one before the fight and I think that
sometimes you can kind of forget that
along the way you know you can just kind
of you can uh
you you can kind of get lost in it but
you know those guys they they just they
never waver from it and and I'm happy
that I'm finally along that path I don't
think that there's a reason ever for me
to to go back into the Hedonism uh I I
can spend the rest of my life and and
and not um enjoy those things and that
could be very tempting right tantalizing
you know the whole world opens up to you
a person becomes you know a great
fighter and then things just start
coming your way right and then sometimes
you know you go down that path and it
and it goes to path of Destruction but
I think it can be tempting if you don't
if you don't have a a bigger purpose if
you don't yeah it's bigger exactly
bigger Outlook exactly and when you
realize like that there's so much in
this life and the Hereafter that that
you have to that you're going to be held
accountable for uh if you don't have
that then yeah it can be very tempted
um which I was when I was young but you
know I'm not a young man anymore I'm a
Madman
you still talk you mentioned Muhammad
you you're in touch with him you guys uh
yeah he's a good friend he's a good
friend he comes to Florida sometimes to
train with us too tell them tell them
I'm looking for him I've had him on a
program we lost touch it's been like a
long time but tell them I give give him
my salaams and tell them I'm looking for
him okay absolutely yeah we gotta hook
up tell me this uh we also had recently
and this is what for me for me really
had me wake up to the reality of what
we're talking about the bigger scheme of
things you know what's the purpose of
life you know just thinking and
contemplating on deaf and we had uh
someone just recently uh Connor I
mentioned his name because now he also
there was something a video of him
getting hit by a car
Conor McGregor and he said man I could I
could have just died you know he said
something along those lines and people
don't think about that you know are you
more conscious of that now the reality
that at any time you know life can be
taken we're all just hanging by a thread
at any time you know everything all this
stuff and all this uh stuff we amass is
going to stay behind yeah and and I uh
martial law didn't have to to go through
a near-death experience like that in
order to to to understand that right I I
think uh I I think you're right I think
it's gonna change him actually I think
it's going to even change Connor um
somebody who who has all the resources
and the biggest ego in the world I I
think uh at the end of the day you you
start to realize once this is all said
and done and once you die and you and
you have to be uh held accountable for
you for all your actions and everything
that you put into this world uh that
that it's it's bound to Humble even even
though the biggest the biggest guys you
know and you hear Mike Tyson talking
about it a lot
um he's somebody that I that I really
look up to he's somebody who's who's who
Conor McGregor kind of pales in
comparison to right when you start
talking about Fame celebrity or all
these worldly things uh he pales in
comparison to Mike and and Mike will
tell you straight up that
you you you're going to be held
accountable for the for these things you
know you you're gonna have to
if something is going to change you no
matter how big and strong you are some
something is going to change you and I
think this is along the paths of of
changing Connor and and hopefully
changing uh the MMA scene in general you
know I I think we we have been stuck in
this whole period of of you know the the
trash talk and the and the sandwich you
need just uh to hyper fight and just to
get people's interests but at what cost
and that what and what cost to yourself
at the end of the day you know once you
once you're done fighting and once you
have kids looking up after you uh at
what costs are are we going to do this
to and and I hope uh if if Conor changes
and if everybody in the in the game
changes
um that it can go towards the the right
path and maybe it could be beaten Garner
was was a way uh for that to start and
like I think that fight was 2018. I'm
not really sure when that fight was but
um yeah I hope that's along the right
Paths of changing the whole game
I wanted this to be us just scratching
the surface because I really look
forward to doing our next uh inshallah
interview there we were supposed to meet
uh if I was there in person uh yeah at
the at the dean Center you're going to
come down it's uh to see us at the the
dean Center so we just acquired the
property alhamdulillah and now we're
working to to get it open
foreign
[Music]
guys so we signed everything here
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
Muslims around here it's it's pretty
huge and uh like this the place the
location that you opened and basically
it's far further south from the other
other big massages and everyone I know a
lot of people that I used to I come my
cousin lives nine minutes from here
another Uncle of mine lives about five
to ten minutes from here this area
opened up in area that it's much needed
and this size yeah I mean this the
center this Center is much needed for
this area and the idea of this Center is
needed for the whole stick because we
don't have anything like that in the
whole state that that was sensor where
it's gonna basically nurture and
basically educate and it's gonna
basically spread Islam
oh
so inshallah this could be a warm-up
where we can go more in depth you know
to more your story I just wanted us to
kind of touch upon some things and make
kind of introduction but inshallah I'd
love to uh do it proper in person yeah
absolutely absolutely inshallah it'll
happen and uh you know I think yeah that
that would be great I feel like in
person is always better right yeah
absolutely yes so uh just a couple more
questions before we conclude so it's
it's nice to see someone like yourself
now you know coming to Islam and just uh
being brave enough and courageous enough
because it sets a good precedence for
for others you know because there's been
so much you know uh bullying with the
kids you know you know as soon as you
say Muslim people start thinking you
know and I think the tide is starting to
turn now people are opening their minds
you know you just had also recently I
don't know if you've heard of this Lex
Friedman
oh yeah yeah he's a good friend of I
think Joe Rogan's he just had any moms
Suleiman on his program
you listen to that today yeah yeah it
was great it was great I mean so I mean
you just can't be of someone you're
sincere if you're looking for the
purpose of life and you hear these
things you know this cat just connect
with the human soul like it did with you
that you can't at least be inquisitive
to want to know more and at the end of
the uh at the end of the road if you
decide to take another pet that's your
that's your that's your right but at
least you know
um you take that step you know to clear
your mind from all this false hype
propaganda that's been out there you
know yeah and I feel like that's that is
a good message that we that we have to
to send to the youth you know I I think
the the stereotypes are definitely out
there
um and I can only speak in my my
personal experience right yeah
um in you know growing up in Detroit and
being around nothing but but but black
people you kind of only associated with
the most extremist forms of of Islam but
when when you really if you really
opened up your heart and you really were
to to dive into into the truth of it is
it's it's just extremely peaceful it is
and these practices have been around for
thousands and thousands of years they're
practiced by billions of people there
there's I hear so many of of like my my
close friends and stuff that will say
okay I'm I'm not religious I'm spiritual
but okay but what does that mean you
know
okay you're spiritual but how do you get
in touch with that spirit and I think uh
the the practices of Islam and the
practices of being a Muslim bring you
more and more in touch with with that
with that Spirit uh if you are spiritual
open your your heart to the billions of
people that that have already
been set in his Spirit they they've been
practicing for a lot longer than you you
can you can learn from other people and
and uh
you don't have to create this I feel
like a lot of people these days are
creating kind of a separation between
themselves and in the in the rest of the
world versus uh us all coming together
and and and really standing and standing
with God
yeah you've uh tweeted you know you've
gotten a lot of love uh from the
community and that uh have you gotten
has there been any kind of pushback has
some any from your family or others that
you know have some kind of
um questions like yeah that you know how
how do you deal with that is it going to
be challenging or does that just does
that increase your motivation to learn
more so you can answer certain questions
that come about yeah exactly uh uh I've
gotten you know people questioning and
people like kind of oh you're not really
like oh what do you believe do you
believe this and that and
um I I've had like Christians trying to
convert me back over
um I've had people straight up tell me
like no you're not a Muslim you were
born Christian you're Christian and I'll
look them and say um no I'm I'm Muslim I
will die a Muslim
um and and you know and then they they
try and you know kind of that that's why
it's very interesting to me because they
will they bring up Jesus and they'll you
know kind of teach me the the lessons of
Jesus
a lot of them I've heard before a lot of
them I've I feel like
and and I don't know maybe you can
educate me here but but let me explain
to you what I hear when people say
um a lot of people will quote the Bible
but
I almost feel like I'll hear the same
quote from the Bible and people will
draw two different conclusions from it
versus when I hear people quote the
Quran I always hear the same message the
exact same message from the Quran
there's no there's no it's not up for
interpretation
that is the word of God and they'll
stick to it whereas people will kind of
use Christianity or or they'll use these
other scriptures and they'll use these
other words and justify whatever actions
that they're taking right now you know
oh I can do this it's okay because the
Bible says this but then another person
will do the exact opposite I can do this
it's okay because the Bible said that
and they'll take the same words and and
flip them around
um
that's just in my personal experience
yeah uh from what I've seen from from
other religions and and like you said
yeah I've had people
people uh come at me in all different
types of ways but it doesn't it doesn't
it'll never sway persuade me you know
it'll never it'll never knock me off my
path I've spent 30 years getting on this
path and there's nothing that can that
can change me
yeah that's the when you know that
you're on the original way just like you
know Islam you were saying this has been
around for you know for since the first
man Adam he was told to submit his will
to the creator of Heaven's Earth he was
a Muslim you know Jesus was a Muslim
Abraham was a Muslim the people say how
what are you talking about because a
Muslim is one who submits his or her
will to the creator of heavens and earth
in the Lord's Prayer or or Our Father
who art in heaven Hallowed be thy name
thy will be one this is Islam and you're
doing the natural way the way of Jesus
of Abraham and Moses you're not
submitting to a human being to money to
your desire to your nests as we called
it you're submitting to the one who
created you and that's the natural way
it's the beautiful way and uh I like
what you said about the when people
quote the Bible obviously we respect you
know people's decisions that they they
live by whatever way of uh what they
live by as Christians and whatnot
they're called people of the book in
Islam but uh we say that now we have the
as you had the Old Testament the New
Testament you have the last and final
Testament that's the verbatim word of
God Almighty the Quran the previous
books they were distorted they were
changed that's why God Almighty Allah
reserved book that we have today
revealed a span of 23 years the Quran so
uh that is uh beautiful it's very very
nice talking with you brother I'm so uh
elated and excited to hear this uh uh
good news straight from you and we
opened up and we said we had a surprise
and we we got the surprise to the people
I'm sure people are going to be so
excited and uh we'll give them something
to look forward to next time inshallah
probably towards the end of the month
I'll be down in Florida inshallah I
would love that yeah yeah we can have a
much more in-depth uh uh uh conversation
I feel yeah I feel there's there's a lot
I can learn from you yeah I'm here from
you brother uh anytime any questions
anything I'm here to help you out as my
my new brother Nadine in Islam thank you
give up give all the brothers down there
is salaams uh give uh if you talk
foreign
thank you so much yes sir yes sir thank
you so much
I cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you're
tuning in to see what these Muslims are
talking about and you like a free copy
of the Quran go and visit thedenshow.com
we'll take care of the postage and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you